Ryan Reynolds is paying tribute to his
roots showing up unannounced while
surprising a class of Canadian broadcast
journalism students yup you heard that
right class was in session when Reynolds
appeared at Seneca College in Toronto
and he documented the whole thing on
social media posting a photo writing
thank you for the tour Seneca College
where something like this existed when I
was starting out hashtag Seneca proud
the Beloved actor even took part in some
teleprompter reading teaming up with a
student to help sharpen his on-air
skills just are you with me
but the Canadian tour didn't stop there
because after a long day of school it's
safe to say Ryan was ready for a hearty
meal yeah that's right making another
surprise appearance Ryan stopped by ill
pastino an Italian restaurant in
Unionville Markham just north of Toronto
the restaurant owners took to their
social media to thank Ryan for his visit
and it's safe to say Canadians certainly
ate well with all the surprise Ryan
Reynolds visits this week